[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 121 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I Mach vandal and I'm here with my
colleague Melanie Weirich Melanie how
are you doing today I'm doing good how
are you doing mark yeah I can hear in
the recording I've definitely got a
gravelly voice from being sick for the
past few weeks I'm getting better slowly
you're surviving I'm surviving the
second wave of the flu is cut both of us
in its wake unfortunately yeah hopefully
this'll be out of the woods soon yeah
hopefully and they're still cut out for
my coffee yeah or leave it in for
authenticity mark who are we talking to
this week I'm really excited about the
interview this week we're talking to one
of my favorite people Parris Pittman
program manager for the kubernetes
community and we're also joined by
garrett rodriguez who is a technical
program manager for google kubernetes
engine we're talking all about how you
can contribute to kubernetes Wow we
never talk about kubernetes no but I
like talking about kubernetes basically
because of the alliteration that I can
use with Kay's nice
yeah and it's it's a good episode
especially I appreciate it when we get a
chance to talk about open source
especially yeah before we get into our
interview as always we talk about our
cool things of the week and our question
of the week yeah so this week comes from
the community we were asked about we
have this wonderful thing called cloud
shell but sometimes you might want to
use a little bit more power so if I need
to increase the power of my cloud shell
maybe temporarily how do I do that well
before we get into all the other things
let's talk about the cool things of the
week so one of the cool things of the
week was at the end of last week there
was the tensorflow dev summit and this
is their second one and they had a
number of announcements and we are going
to include in our show notes as always
we'll include a link that gives you the
highlights from that but a couple things
that stood out especially were they've
announced tensorflow hub which is a
space that they're using to help share
and allow people to reuse models that
have been trained and pre trained and
includes weights it allows people to
take that and you know use that to
improve their own models for
generalization or speed up their
training they've also announced that
they're supporting more languages like
Swift and JavaScript and they have these
additional components that they've been
building out to help build a more
extensive full scale machine learning
platform to incorporate things like
Apache beam so there's a number of
resources and links and
so and they're also integrating with and
videos tensor RT which is a library that
optimizes deep learning models for
inference I know that's a lot of stuff
it's very cool stuff it's all the cool
stuff that looks good but we do have
more cool things in the week this tensor
hub thing looks cool yeah it's nice to
have actual content that you can share
and reuse and not have to start from
scratch okay
another cool thing of the week if that's
not tensorflow machine learning
there is the RSA conference that's
coming up and that's happening the 16th
through the 20th of April and so we have
a link that we're going to share that
will announce the Google cloud security
talks that are taking place in jarring
the actual RSA Conference like Ian
goodfellas going to be speaking about
security machine learning but we also
have our separate side event that's
going to be going on that has a host of
a number of different types of talks
around security that's taking place
April 17th and 18th in San Francisco and
we were saying this before it's at the
Westfield Center you know aka the
Westfield Mall so you can go shopping
too apparently it's about a five minute
walk from Moscow and apparently nice
yeah thing so yes we will include a link
for people to check out what specific
talks are happening and when and see all
the things around security I definitely
at the RSA Conference there's a thing
called post quantum cryptography yes I
think I only know what two of those
words mean or maybe one of them post
posted and actually we're gonna be doing
a podcast after this event that's going
to talk a little bit about quantum
security but I'll be later in the month
cool that'll be fun all right mark any
cool things of the week on your end yeah
so we were actually speaking of security
that's my lovely Segway there's a really
good blog post that came out the other
day from oh my god I dimed gonna
massacre this last name seems like a
thing we need to do every week now which
is the thing
maiya Qasr has a rope ski possibly they
are product managers for security and
privacy they do a wonderful article
called exploring container security
so it's an overview of all the different
things you can do when container izing
your applications particularly running
them on current Indies and the various
layers that you have that you can apply
for providing security everything from
infrastructure logging to secrets as
well as Network all sorts of other good
stuff so if you're building applications
using containers and kubernetes for
security purposes you might want to
check that out it's really really nice
cool
anything else did you want to talk about
yeah well since we're talking about
containers always one of our fellow
developer advocates met a he has written
an article about how to run Windows
containers on compute engine we don't
talk about Windows often enough I think
but it's obviously a huge ecosystem so
basically if you're looking to run
Windows containers on compute engine he
has a step-by-step guide for creating a
container getting it started getting it
up and running and getting it all going
little video in there as well so mint 8
doesn't excellent job yeah I like stuff
that gives you the step by step and then
also video that's that's a nice value
add so great well mark shall we go talk
about kubernetes sure why not why not so
today I am really excited we have two
wonderful people here we have Parris
Pittman co-chair of the contributor
experience special interest group for
kubernetes as well as Gerrit Rodriguez
the technical lead of the contributor
experience a special interest group for
kubernetes while those mouthful
thank you so much for joining us today
how you both doing Paris I am very well
and very excited to be here yeah how you
doing yeah likewise I'm really happy to
be on the podcast awesome so I'm super
happy the two of you could join us today
I've been really excited I'm Paris and I
work in the same office we get along
really well so hopefully that comes
through but we wanted to talk today
about contributing to communities the
experience of like people who want to
come on and get involved with this
product and so I thought you two would
be great for doing that but before we
get stuck into that do you want to tell
us a little bit about both of you and
who you are and what you do here at
Google I am on a newly formed team on
Google cloud under Sarah Novotny
managing open-source strategy for the
cloud of my specific area is kubernetes
yes I'm a Technical Program Manager
enjoying Google
about a year and a half ago and I wasn't
too familiar with kubernetes when I
joined it was a relatively small team of
engineers or a group of us we could all
fit in a room at that point and since
then the project has taken off both in
the open source but the number of Google
engineers contributing to it as well so
I'm very excited to be part of that
massive growth
I definitely consider myself to be a new
contributor as well and only been on for
about six months so good good
perspective here awesome okay so talking
about contributing securities let's take
it from a high level I'm sure a lot of
people know this but I'd love to get
your takes on it as well what do you
feel is like the 30,000 foot view of
kubernetes like as a whole okay I'll get
started so it is a complex beast I think
there's something like 30 special
interest groups so we organized
ourselves 35 35 are you kidding working
groups as well yes there are tears of
contribution and we organize ourselves
into special interest groups so that's
probably a good place to start and these
special interest groups can come in kind
of three flavors vertical horizontal or
project-based vertical is like a
specific area within the kubernetes
ecosystem you can think of it as like a
technical area of focus node might be
one networking might be another
kubernetes api horizontal maybe
something that encompasses many SIG's
like architecture I think is one and
then project is something like what we
do which is a contributor experience or
stick release which are dedicated to
kind of improving how you get started
contributing to the project or sig
release into making sure that we have
stable well tested well-documented
releases on a regular cadence and just
to echo the large we do have 52
repositories under the kubernetes
organization on github which is very
large and that includes core and core
here would be kubernetes kubernetes so
then we're talking about a very very
large ecosystem of things that are being
built on top of so when people talk
about contributing to kubernetes you
really do have to kind of get down into
the granule or ask of contributing what
and where do kubernetes because that
could be a lot of things in a lot of
different reap
that sounds scary yes definitely and I
think that contributor experience has
been working on ways to not make that
scary a less scary scary more
sustainable maintainable and making sure
that the contributor has as much of a
similar to same process across those
repos as possible which can definitely
be a challenge because some of those
repos are you know essentially different
projects and may also have different
workflows so Garrett and myself and LC
who's another co-chair and many many
other folks in the contributor
experience sig have been working on
issues just like that so we keep using
this where it's a special interest group
what is this thing it's really a way to
break down the project maintain code
ownership which is something that we are
trying to undergo right now with a lot
of things that the steering committee
has been pushing out as far as
standardization of SIG's and sig
charters and therefore you know cleaning
code ownership with that but these
special interest groups are really
pushing the vision for their area of the
project so for instance sig networking
sig node those are some of our larger
groups and push different projects
related to those special interests yeah
as the project scale one more time
coming back to two massive massive scale
we've been focusing more on how we
organize the project and SIG's was kind
of the natural way of doing it I think
that was form prior to me joining the
project in 2016 and the idea is that
these SIG's are responsible for various
areas and they're forced to talk to each
other when they have cross dependencies
within the project more recently we've
been defining the governance in greater
detail I think within the last few weeks
we've been talking about splitting the
rolls out into chairs for the sig people
that are technical leads and similar to
tiel's at Google who are responsible for
kind of the oversight of the overall
interests of the sig and then sub
project leads who drive individual
projects within a special interest group
and who runs it
who runs the sig anyone who's nominated
right now I mean each sig already has
leads and now chairs the
- chair title change is actually very
recent as of I believe it's a week ago
but these chairs ultimately run the sig
and they were vetted through some kind
of nomination process at that time of
creation so for instance if you're in
the project right now and you have the
idea for a cig you would propose the sig
on the K dev and ke dev meaning
kubernetes development mailing list and
pretty much nominate either yourself or
other people to run it and then you
would ultimately get nominated through
plus one system yeah when you say run
the cig there are so many facets to that
as well there's driving technical
projects but then there are the
day-to-day things that come up with
running a project that serves
contributors from all over the world so
that's things like making sure that our
milestones are well published our
roadmap our goals for the quarter our
goals for release are published in an
agreement that videos are uploaded to
YouTube so people who can't make the
meeting times are able to discover them
making sure that their meeting notes
making sure that information is
communicated widely and that's done
across various members of the kubernetes
community the chair handles some of it
tech leads are responsible for some of
it so it's just a matter of working
together and kind of a very large large
community do all SIG's have the same
structure or does it vary from cig to
sig it definitely varies from sig to
sake I think we're going to start seeing
more standardization now that the
steering committee has weighed on things
like charter templates and other kind of
uniform procedures but it really just
depends on what that signe so you know
if the sig doesn't have a need for
technical guidance then they don't
necessarily have a technical lead but
the the template that the steering
committee has pushed down it's more of
guidance than it is a mandate so you
know it's just to each sig you know
their own if you will on on those
matters yeah but you bring up a great
point which is consistency and that's
something that contributes and the
steering committee and a lot of other
people who've been around the project
for a while been focusing on which is
how do we make sure that you know moving
from one thing to another or moving from
one repo to another
you get kind of a consistent experience
when you're contributing so first SIG's
very recently we've merged that the
Charter template and if you go into the
community repo so it's kubernetes slash
community it's a github repository you
can actually see that template starting
to get filled out for a number of the 35
SIG's that call out you know who the
chair is that technically is what the
sub projects are they're all done
declaratively which is another theme in
kubernetes so that there's there's not a
trail and you can actually see the state
of the world in the repo I'm new to
kubernetes and let's say I want to
contribute what would be my first step
first step is to check the contributor
guide that's always a very good easy way
of getting a sort of beginner checklist
the contributor guide lives now on the
community repo under contributor and
inside of the guide folder we'll put
links on the show notes yes of course
and the guide actually has a great story
behind it which we can get to in a
second but we have some awesome
community members that have been pushing
out this new style of contributor guide
previously we had just our growing
community help us with contributor
documentation which you know now has
issues of just Doc's getting outdated
links going bad things like that so now
we are starting to centralize that
process under the under that contributor
folder but the contributor guides a
great first step because then you'll see
things like how to sign the CLA what our
labeling system looks like on github how
to set up your dev environment and to
just get the really basic things right
there I think a good second step is to
join the slack the slack is very robust
with 30,000 people on it that means
contributors as well as users which
equals kubernetes community and then
also mailing lists of certain SIG's and
things like that and there is a sake
list also in the community repo as well
that'll be linked to the the show notes
I mean that sounds like so much
information as well which is great thank
you Paris so if I am coming to
contribute to communities do you think I
should be focusing on like a specific
sig like do I do that
where's my entry point you know what I
mean your entry point depends on you I
think and I think our experienced
developers who for instance already have
go experience may already know where
their value at is so for instance if
they really love ipv6 and that's their
thing then they would probably know to
go to some kind of networking group in
which they would find out on the sick
list that hey there is a cig networking
let's be a fly on the wall and their
mailing list and their slack channel and
kind of see what's up from there or the
another entry point which we've seen a
lot of people come in from is
documentation as a user they see that
the docs are wrong and they plug in from
that perspective and then the
contributor guides story is actually one
very much like that I was here for a
month knew at the time that the
contributor guide was a high priority
but again here for a month deer in
headlights
hi it's kubernetes and I had a woman
come to me through various different
channels and she said hey I'm a new
contributor I just started at Samsung
her name's Gwen shout out to Gwen and
England hey your contributor guide
really sucks but - I'm so glad to hear
that you're on board and passionate
about contributing and hey we really
need somebody to help us with this
contributor guide and and here we are we
have an MVP for contributor guide from
Gwyn and company so yeah absolutely
that's one of the things we talk about
all the time in the kubernetes community
I think they've even given out awards at
some of the coop cons for chopping wood
and carrying water there's a lot of work
and there's a lot of really exciting
feature work to be done in kubernetes
but everyone's got to start somewhere
and I think a good way to learn our
process is to get involved with Lake
Perris ed some of the documentation work
testing is a great place to get involved
if I were getting started for the first
time ever I would probably try and get
you know hope that I found my way to the
kubernetes community repo that way I
could see the organization of the
project from there you can find all of
the SIG's and all of their meeting times
another really valuable resource in
there if you want to get started and
like kubernetes and like the history is
all the design proposals are and they're
to bring down by special interest group
so if you go I think it's in the
contributor folder we can add this link
as well to the podcast but all the
design proposals are there and if you
said you know you're interested in the
networking say you're the nodes say you
can see like a history of all the design
proposals you can even look at the code
reviews going into them and some of the
discussions surrounding them so it's a
good place to kind of get some of that
technical information and see the
discussions kind of happening it's
important to note that finding a cig
should not be the most important thing
to do the first time you contribute to
kubernetes you really should find your
entrance point and there are as you know
we just laid out here multiple I mean
even another just standard github entry
point if you will is just our labels we
have the Help Wanted label some of the
repos are using good first time or for
new contributors and that's again that's
also something that Garrett and I are
working on and and other folks in the
contributor experience group to get
labels standardized across the board and
have other repos use things like good
first time issue or Help Wanted
consistently but there are definitely
repos right there that use all of the
above so if you are like I said before
an experienced contributor you can
indeed just jump right in through issues
actually we've mentioned it a couple of
times I just kind of want to highlight
it as well many all I don't know the
cigs they run meetings
so there's actually in-person meetings
that you can go to it's not just all
online is that correct that's correct
this SIG's do have their regular online
meetings which are either weekly
bi-weekly depending on their cadence and
ultimately exactly depending on some of
them I feel like we're releasing so much
you wonder if they are meeting our
league no but then we also do face to
face meetings at cube con and now we
have three cube cons a year one in
Seattle one in Copenhagen one in China
and there they have 30 minute update
sessions as well as deep dive sessions
and then they also do face to face
meetings most of them do at this point
anyway and that's just coming together
at least annually just to get stuff done
and set things and depending on what
their needs are like for instance helm
just had a helm summit shout out to the
helm crew
but yeah so if I'm a new contributor
should I go to one of these meetings or
is this just for the experience people I
would say that probably wouldn't be your
best entrance point but I think the sake
updates at cube con would be awesome for
that I wouldn't necessarily say the face
to face because I guess that's really
where they're doing deep dives into some
of the issues that they're working on
for instance storage had one in q4 last
year and they really concentrated
heavily on CSI the CSI implementation
and things like that so I think
newcomers might be lost to that
conversation but definitely the updates
for sure I mean that's where we owe the
community an update of what we've been
doing there's also the the contributor
summit as well that we have now where
it's all contributors and we're going to
be building out a new contributor track
Jorge Castro with hefty owe and several
other people myself are planning that so
that'll be a good time as well is that a
separate event or is that part of a cube
cone that's technically a separate event
technically a part of cube con they're
calling it a co-located event it is on
Mayday for Copenhagen so May first and
it is free and no you don't need a
ticket to cube con to attend so if you
are a new contributor and listening
right now please feel free to go to the
website it's a Google form that's why
it's a Google form and not through the
website as we mentioned all the
community stuff I think we missed the
elephant in the room which is the weekly
community meeting state of the world and
that's more to project-wide level we
talked about all the sig meetings
everything is hosted on Zoom but every
Thursday at 10:00 a.m. Pacific time
there's a kubernetes community meeting
and we talk about things like the
current release there's usually a demo
of a product or project within
kubernetes or something that runs on top
of kubernetes so you kind of get a feel
of how people are using the project and
there's also sig updates there as well
so that's a really good place to kind of
get a 10,000 foot view of the state of
the world how does somebody get to demo
at that meeting there is a agenda
document on the calendar invite that you
can find on kubernetes that IO slash
community and in the
at the top you just pretty much add your
name to the demo list I think right now
we're probably in a may on that list
it's yeah definitely if you're out there
listening to and want a demo to at least
you know three hundred plus people
weekly get on now even if I'm just a
user of coop entities that actually
sounds like it could just be useful as
well know for sure definitely I mean I
think I think we really want users to be
as much into our community as possible I
think a lot of people think community
just means contributors but users should
plug in because then they'll be able to
see what we are rolling out as far as
innovations and features and things like
that so they are prepared ahead of time
and that's the best place to get that
information before you're saying
something about helm
what does helm helm sure it falls under
sig apps such as short for applications
and it is a package manager for
kubernetes so it's an easier way to
customize and deploy applications they
have a bunch of I guess what they call
charts I'm not too involved with siga
I'm probably doing a poor job of
explaining it right now but more
information there are there are a couple
repos there's the helm repo and the
charts repo and you can see all the
applications they have there if you want
to get started installing my sequel or a
WordPress application helm is a one of
the ways that you can actually do that
that's so it's one of 52 repos and that
gigantic organization on github yeah
that's crazy so I've done some work
doing small contributions inside
kubernetes I've noticed a lot of its
automated there's a lot of build tools
and build BOTS and things like that can
you tell us a little bit about how that
whole system works absolutely that's
sort of where I jumped in on the project
so there's a cig dedicated to tooling
and automation and it's gonna be sick
testing and they own what's called the
test infrastructure repository and as
the project scale became really
important to make sure that the
processes were streamlined you can
imagine with 3,000 plus contributors if
someone had to manually merge your PR
after doing a code review doing that
across so many contributors would be
time consuming and bottlenecks would
appear all over the place so we tried to
leverage some of the experience from
other large open source projects from
Google internally to manage
the code review process so that we
require code review from people who are
more experienced we require people to
demonstrate ownership over certain areas
within the project there's actually two
tiers of code review that are required
there's LG TM which is sort of like a
stylistic review and making sure that
your code fits within the kubernetes
contributing standards and then there's
approval as well which is someone who is
really familiar with that section of the
repositories is someone who owns the
node team kind of a TL from like the
node side or the networking side or
wherever you're contributing to also
approve the changes after two people
have indicated their levels of approval
two or more it's actually it can be more
complex than that so it's worth reading
the contributor guide there's actually
automation that will automatically
recognize that you have sufficient
approval and then magically merge your
PR so you get put into a submit queue
everything is kind of batch tested
there's a suite of tests that must pass
pre submit tests and when that's done
and successful your code is merged there
are lots more requirements depending on
the time of the quarter so if it's
during what's called code freeze which
were actually in right now only testing
fixes should beginning and so no
features can get in there's kind of a
complex process for contributing and
again this is why we have that very long
complex contributor guide but the idea
is to spell it out and make things as
efficiently as possible you can actually
see on dev stats which is project that
Garrett helped kick off it's it's Kate
stock dev stats dot C and C F dot IO
another link that will give you but this
is an awesome way to check the stats of
the project but you can actually see I
just wanted to shout that out you can
actually see some of the issues start to
level off as we started to increase
automation on certain areas and add in
things like bot labeling and things like
that so that's really kind of how we're
measuring to you know is this stuff
working why are you guys in code freeze
right now so we are just before a
release the last month of the quarter
generally we prepare for the minor
release of kubernetes I believe it's
really signal Wednesday March 26 you
know the date sounds good enough to me
so the last four weeks are dedicated to
stabilization
so the quarters generally broken up with
seven or eight weeks of development time
we're features are being submitted and
this feature work being done and then we
work on making sure that all of those
tests are passing before cutting a
release oh and plug for the release team
for new contributors and current
contributors they have roles on every
release and even new contributors can
take the third seat role to kind of see
what's going on in the lay of the land
so that they could step up for other
releases so it sounds like there's
opportunities there to contribute to
kubernetes itself it's documentation as
well as all its automation and release
processing across the board that is
absolutely and there's mentors that
you're we were talking about briefly
you also have mentors that people can
work with yes right now I'm building out
it's I think we're at four to five
programs right now on all in an
incubator is incubating because a lot of
the programs that we're running are
either a new to kubernetes or being new
to mentoring and open source in general
like the concept of group mentoring and
open source so we're testing all those
things out right now but if you are
interested in anything mentorian related
or to be a part of the tests there is a
mentoring folder in the community repo
as well and you can check the readme out
there what's your favorite color
kubernetes blue black like my soul
[Music]
like we need to have a therapy session
now is there anything we haven't
mentioned you want to make sure you get
in any events coming up or any special
things going on or really just anything
at all your favorite dogs I'm talking
like over that too so as part of the
mentoring deal one of the tests that
were running is a monthly series called
meet our contributors it's sort of
mentors on demand if you will so we're
trying to solve for time on everybody's
part there and we have between four to
seven contributors monthly come on for
two different time zones and we
essentially livestream on YouTube and
ask questions from the meet our
contributors select channel as well as
Twitter and it's pretty much anything
from what is your favorite color to the
contributor to how the heck do eet eet
tests work I'm very confused my tests
are failing so it's literally anything
that you'd like to ask and again that's
the first Wednesday of the month and you
can get a copy of the calendar via the
community website on the kubernetes site
well Paris Garrett thank you so much for
hanging out with us and spending time
with us and talking to us all about
contributing to kubernetes Thanks yes
thank you so much for having us so
thanks again to Paris and Garrett for
joining us today I love chatting about
kubernetes love talking about open
source I hope that's a useful thing for
anyone who's looking to get involved
with the group entities ecosystem write
some code write some documentation just
get stuck in definitely it was good to
get all the insights around kubernetes
so how to be involved in it so mark
question of the week yeah
so thanks out to one of our community
members justin garrison he sent in a
wonderfully interesting question
actually that I didn't even know existed
which was super cool so the question was
basically if I need to temporarily
increase the power of the cloud shell VM
how do I do that
so maybe I'm doing some extra processing
or I want to do something that's
computationally intensive what do I do
so there's a boost mode that you can use
and that's something you can find very
easily in the cloud shell section and so
when you choose that it apparently will
temporarily increase the power of your
cloud shell VM from a default g1 small
machine type offering to an in one
standard one the
instance so yeah I'd so like basically
I'm going back to my childhood and
remembering the turbo button yes my
computer it should be called turbo and
red yeah like totally you just left it
on like I just left on like I was ever
like why would you turn this off it's
worth noting though once activated all
sessions will be boosted for the next 24
hours and enabling boost mode will
restart your cloud shell and immediately
terminate your session so just be
prepared for that it is an experimental
feature so additional limits may be
implemented in the future but if you
need that kind of power it's there
available which is kind of cool yes
definitely
I love cloud fun and effective well mark
so this past weekend we had April Fool's
and Easter and a blue moon all at once
did you do anything fun for all of it I
was really sick did you see anything
cool and happy and exciting I saw some
people wearing some fun hats okay that
was cute that's cool lots of fun hats
out there actually but I hope everybody
had a good one yeah are you up to
anything exciting or interesting coming
up in the next few weeks yes I will be
speaking about AI at a training boot
camp called tectonic ax on April 11th
and then I'm also going to be
participating in a panel on diversity
inclusion at the Harker research
symposium on April 14th mark are you
gonna be anywhere no actually so I just
finished up with GDC so now I actually
have to plan out the rest of my year so
I'm gonna have been sick but I mean did
you technically get some rest and some
downtime after Jesus I did I took a
couple of days off so it's been good so
I will get better soon I promise
oh good well I think that's it for us
this week yeah well Melanie thank you
very much for joining me for yet another
episode of the podcast thank you and
thank you everyone for listening and
we'll see you all next week
[Music]
[Music]